Hello, my name is Ryan Wade.
I'm a Senior Cloud Solution
Architect for Microsoft,
specializing in data and AI.
I'm here to present to you
the topic covering the
integration in Power BI
and why you as R
developers to be interested.
I am very passionate
about both R and Power BI,
so much so that I
wrote a book about it.
I understand that many
R developers do not
share the same passion
about Power BI that I do.
Many of you all
may be saying, why
should I even be interested
in R integration in Power BI?
And probably the reason why is
because the Power BI community
needs you.
So before I get into
the meat of this talk,
I want you all to know what
this talk is not about.
This talk is not about me trying
to convince you to replace
your Shiny apps with Power BI.
You are able to
do things in Shiny
from our visual standpoint
that you can't do in Power BI
and I'm not trying to convince
you to make that switch.
I am not trying to convince
you to refactor the notebooks
that you develop in Jupyter
Notebooks or R Markdown
or Quarto and replace
that with Power BI.
Those are two different tools.
Or those tools have a different
purpose than what Power BI
have.
So I would not try to convince
you to make that change.
And also, I'm not going
to tell you to say
and I'm not going to tell
you to start doing your R
development in Power BI
and ditch RStudio.
I am not trying to
convince you to do that.
Microsoft
is not trying
to convince you
to do that either.
Microsoft gives you
the option to do
your development in RStudio
when you're
writing code
that its purpose is for Power BI.
So that is what the
talk is not about.
What the talk is
about is to address
the disconnect between
some R developers
and Power BI developers.
Both sides have
their own perception
of what the other
tool is, and often
that perception is not correct.
So we're going to address that.
I'm also going to
try to introduce
Power BI to some
R developers that
is not familiar with the tool.
You probably heard of it,
but you probably never really
seen it in action.
So I'm going to try
to introduce it to you
and give you a high level
understanding of what
Power BI is.
And then I'll give you some
examples of the integration
so that you can
say, wow, Ryan was
able to do these
things in Power BI.
Based off of how
he's using the functionality,
maybe I can do
these other things
that Ryan hasn't thought of.
And then lastly, lastly, I will
show you how to get started.
So first, let's address
some of the disconnect.
There are a lot of
unknown unknowns
that R developers
have about Power BI
and that Power BI
developers have about R.
From our standpoint, when R
developers look at Power BI,
they just see another GUI
based data visualization tool.
Power BI is much more than that.
And in this talk, I will show
you the reason behind that.
And then on the
Power BI side,
when property
developers look at R,
they see a domain
specific programming language
that they think is just for data
scientists and statisticians.
They don't realize that a lot
of the things that Power BI attempts
to do have been done in
the R community for some time
now, since the
nineties, I think.
R was developed in
the early 90s, by 93.
So the R community has been
doing things from a data
visualization standpoint
That the Power BI community
has recently started
doing so we will address that.
Well, that's on the other side.
When I'm doing
different types of talk,
I try to tell the
Power BI community
some of the things that
you can do using that tool
that they're not aware of.
So now that I got that
address, the disconnect,
let me introduce Power BI to
some of you that are new to it
from a high level.
Power BI is a data
visualization tool.
So in order to do data
visualization,
you need data.
And the data model
that Power BI  prefers
is a data model known as
the star schema data model.
The star schema data
model is made up of
two types of tables: a dimension
table and a fact table.
The fact table you see here in
the center and the fact table
stores measures.
You can think of a
measure as something
that measures a
business activity.
And this particular
simple example,
we see that the measures
are price and quantity.
And then the fact
table is connected
to the dimension table.
And then the dimension
tables you have
dimensions grouped by category.
So you see in this
particular example,
we have a store dimension,
a employee dimension
and so on and so forth.
You can read the screen and
those different categories.
You have dimensions that
you can group your measures
and your fact table by.
Another thing I
want to point out
about Power BI from a data
standpoint is how the data is
stored in Power BI.
Power BI uses an engine
called a VertiPaq engine.
And the take away
I want you to get
from that is that
the VertiPaq engine
one, stores a data memory using
what is called column store
indexing.
And the takeaway
you should get is
that storing data in that
fashion does two things.
It makes performance, you
know, some complex calculation
relatively faster than you
will then what it will perform
if you're using another tool.
And in addition to that, the
column store indexing increases
the memory footprint
of your data by a lot,
in some cases up to a tenth of
the size of the original data
set.
So the second thing I want to
point out is the built-in data
wrangling tool that's in Power BI.
This built in data
wrangling tool,
if you are using
Microsoft Excel,
this tool is built
into that as well.
This is like a gym that many
people don't know about.
This tool is called Power Query,
and this tool, using a GUI,
allows you to do many
types of data wrangling
tasks with low code.
Super easy.
A person who has no
coding experience
can do a lot of
complex data wrangling
that we in the R
community will probably
have to write a dplyr
script to do with no code.
And then in the instances
where you need to use code,
it has a programming language
underneath the hood called M
that you can write some code
to do some things that you
can't do throughout the GUI.
Super powerful and again is
built in Microsoft Excel,
so it's a tool you should
look into if you're
doing any type of data wrangling
in Microsoft Excel as well,
and this is what the
interface looks like,
and you'll see that
the interface is
similar to some of the
other Office products.
So the learning
curve with getting up
to speed with this particular
tool is pretty shallow.
The feature that I the
best about Power BI
are the calculated measures.
What I like
about calculated measures
is the way they operate
inside of Power BI.
They are what I
call context-based,
meaning that they calculate
based off of the context
that you put them in.
So in this particular situation,
we have a simple matrix
where we're displaying
three different measures,
and those measures are the sales
amount calculated measures,
and those are the
sales amount calculated
measure, the comparison
sales amount
calculated measure, and adjusted
comparison sales amount
calculated measure.
One thing I want to
point out is that we
look at the highlighted
cell, in that cell,
the comparison sales
amount calculated
measure is calculated in the
context of the events work
brand and also the context
of the comparison date filter
that you see in the slide
filter and on the upper right
portion of the screen.
Notice I didn't
mention the filter that
was being applied by
the other date slicer
and I only mentioned
the slicer on the right.
That is because the
programming language
that Power BI uses, a
called DAX, Data Analysis
Expression, programming
language.
It allows you to incorporate
some pretty sophisticated
business logic inside of it.
And in this
particular situation,
you can see that we were able
to remove the filter from one
of the slicers and we
only got the filter that
was applied in the slicers
in the upper right.
Super powerful feature.
You will be surprised at
the type of business logic
that you can encapsulate
inside of a DAX expression
using Power BI.
And then, of course, it's
a data visualization tool.
So just like any other
data visualization
tool,
whether you're
talking about Power
BI, Qlik, Tableau,
I know we have a speaker talking
about that particular tool.
You can build dashboards
and get as artsy as you want.
You know, you can
get real pretty.
I'm not good at that aspect.
You know, I do
everything pretty bland,
but if you are a
very colorful person,
you can do that or
you can pretty much do
any type of visual you
want and Power BI just
like you can with any
other visualization tool.
Now up to this point,
you may be saying, Ryan,
you just described a
pretty awesome tool.
Why do we even need the R
integration inside of Power BI?
How do we even
benefit from this?
Well, this is my opinion.
This little graph right here.
This is my opinionated view
about how I think Power BI is.
This is my assessment of
Power BI using these four
different categories.
And in these four
different categories,
you see in most
of the categories,
I think Power BI is
a very awesome tool
other than the data
science model piece.
It does a good job at
data visualization,
data wrangling for the most
part, for most situations.
And then from a context
based calculation
that I showed you earlier, that
feature right there in
Power BI is awesome.
Now in the data science modeling
side of things is very limited
and that you normally would
need the premium capacity
version of Power BI to
be able to leverage Azure
Machine Learning services.
And you can do some data
modeling there and then
connect to Power BI from there.
Or you can use some
prebuilt data models
in the form of Azure
Cognitive Services.
So from that standpoint,
it still is kind of clunky
and I don't really recommend it.
But when you add R
to the situation,
you'll see that from
a data viz, there be
in 80 to 80%
to 90% of the time,
you have a visual that's
already baked in the Power BI
or that you can get
from the Microsoft Store
to import into Power BI.
But there would be
those edge cases where
if you are used to coding
in ggplot, you can, you know,
create that visual
easily in ggplot,
but you can't do in
Microsoft. That is what
that orange is representing.
And then on the
data wrangling side,
there are situations where you
may need a regular expression
to do some type of
upstream manipulation,
or you may need to
do something that is
pretty clunky to do in Power BI
but you can easily
do it in dplyr
and those situations is
represented by the orange
there.
And then on the
data modeling side,
if you're doing
something in data science
where you want to
bring in scores data
into your Power BI data
model, if you use them
in Power BI in a self
service fashion,
you can take those
R scripts that you
have that will
ingest in data scored
and you can take that scored data
and easily adjust in Power BI.
That's why I added that
little orange for the data
science modeling piece.
So now let's talk
about some examples.
The first example is a very
simple data science machine
learning example,
using a data set that,
if you were learning any
type of data science,
you'd probably be familiar
with this data set.
The Boston Housing data set and
it's a very simple illustration
of how you can take a model that
was saved in an .Rds file on disk,
consume that model, and then
consume the data that you
need for the scoring.
And just like you do in any
other situation with R,
you can use that model and the
new data that you want to score,
score it and then
present that data
to Power BI as the data set.
If you had a more
complex workflow,
you all that went to the
tidyverse workshop here,
or if you're familiar
with tidymodels,
you can use tidymodels
if you have
a more sophisticated
workflow that you need to do
prior to scoring the data.
And once you score
that data, the caveat
is that data set needs to
be exposed as a data frame.
If this is exposed
as a data frame
that you can bring in Power BI.
If you have it in any other data
structure or list, Power BI
would not be able to read it.
Another aspect that I
like when using the R
integration in
Power BI is if I need
to read a data from a data API.
In this particular
example, I'm reading data
from the US Census.
And I can easily consume data
from a data API using an R
from a Power Query standpoint.
They have some integration,
but it's very costly
and it's not as
performance as using R.
So in this situation,
I'm looking at, I'm
integrating the Census API,
bringing in data, and exposing
that data to Power BI,
and you'll see that it will
be exposed to Power BI as a dataset.
That can be extremely
valuable when you're using
outside data to bring
more value to the data
that you have in house.
Now, the thing I the best is
the data visualization piece
in terms of the R integration
and this example,
this visual is near to me.
This is the visual where I was,
it was the first
visual I built when
the R integration
became available in Power BI
and in this situation you see
that we are able to do things
with R that, we're spoiled,
but the Power BI community
don't even know of some
of these capabilities.
One of those capabilities
is the ability
to have annotations
inside of your graph.
Now, in this particular
graph, if you
were to add up all
the different classes,
you see that the numbers
don't add to the total number
of countries, to 235 countries.
And I'm able to add
information in my title
about why that's the case
for each individual violin
plot that's overlaid
with a box plot.
I'm able to get
information about that,
the number of countries that
was in that particular core
class and the trade balance
for that particular class,
those type of annotations in
the Power BI community, they're
not aware of.
And those were one of the things
that make it super powerful.
Another thing is, if you
want to choose another year,
you'll see that I can
easily pick a button
and then that filter will
be propagated to my visual.
And if I wanted to look
at this and I say, OK,
looking over to
the left-hand side
and I see that the
Caribbeans for instance,
we have a positive trade
experience with the Caribbean.
So if you look at
the left-hand side,
I can drill down further
into that information
and get detailed information
using the Power BI
functionality.
So this is our visual.
And if we're on the R
side, we're used
to be able to be this
expressive with our visuals,
but not on the Power BI side.
And you as R developers
should reach out
to some of your people in
the Power BI community and, you know,
teach them how the R
integration can
be super beneficial to them.
I gave you some
examples here, but there
are many more examples that if
once you start digging into it,
you'll be able to find
out more examples.
And in your unique
use cases, you
can use also to be creative
with using that R integration
inside of Power BI.
That's the end of
this presentation.
If you want, you can
go to this GitHub site
and I have a little GitHub repo
that gives you some high level
information about leveraging
the R integration inside of Power BI.
I appreciate you
all coming to the talk
and listening to me tell you
about this R integration
and I hope you
go out and spread the
love of the R community
to other Power BI
developers and show them
why we love the
great programming
language of R. Thank you.